wait you won a game with zero nine
question mark it's kind of what i do i
inked my ass off and then i still win
the baus is known for terrorizing
european solo queue in league of legends
with his unique scion gameplay which
involves dying taking turrets dying and
then winning recently he's been playing
on the korean server it seems like the
pros and high elo players there have
never seen anything quite like the
bounce before and to be honest they
don't really know what to do with him
was temporarily locked out of his
account by mistake when many thought
he'd been banned for entering a game
where faker was on his team faker did
the surrounding
this is so embarrassing i can't man oh
my god a lot of people said his
playstyle wouldn't work over there but
he's been dominating and recently he
finally reached challenger on the korean
server it's impressive but for the boss
he's far from finished god dale